[Musique]
non
c'est peut-être le plus classique des
artistes programmés
pierre christophe quartet fait
redécouvrir erroll garner célèbre
pianiste des années 50 le vésinet jazz
métis festival m remonter aux origines
du style c'est un festival qui a cette
particularité de de vouloir faire mettre
en valeur les groupes de jazz qui
s'inspirent de leurs racines delà des
traditions des différents bugs en
afrique soit d'amérique latine soit des
caraïbes et qui en font un jazz
contemporain donc on a des groupes qui
viennent des états unis mais chaque fois
qu'ils puisent dans l'histoire quatre
dates
quatre styles pour attirer amateurs et
passionnés famille et individuelles au
jazz académique succès de la salsa du
spanish harlem orchestra
[Musique]
c'est un moyen de voyager avec vue des
grandes soirées des grandes soirées jazz
sous le grand plateau est aussi le
vendredi soir et le samedi soir c'est
une fête dans le théâtre parce que avant
et après il ya des groupes de musique
qui permettent de de rester avec des
amis le san francisco jazz collective et
arat kilo complète cette nouvelle
édition du festival des artistes venus
des quatre coins du monde pour un aller
simple vers les états unis
[Musique]